I'm quotation aha a teacher East Asian
Buddhism in the double
is at yale and i'd like to welcome you
to this 40s hume lecture human lecture
is a very important event for the castle
on East Asian Studies at Yale and we are
very lucky unfortunate to have professor
Stephen tiser from Princeton University
to give the lecture this year there is a
reception after that lecture upstairs so
please proceed after the lecture on the
discussion upstairs and have a more
informal conversation I now invite
professor Stanley Weinstein who taught
Chinese and Japanese Buddhism at Yale
for many years and very very
productively and turned yell into a
major center of east asian buddhist
studies in north america and in the
world thank you for the kind words on
behalf of the council on East Asian
Studies I'd like to welcome all of you
to today's Edward humhum oriole lecture
which is the 48th lecture in this series
the Council on East Asian Studies is
honored to have professor Stephen tizer
who holds the dt suzuki professorship in
buddhist studies at Princeton University
the council thanks professor Thaisa for
graciously agreeing to give this year's
Hume lecture and by so doing he has
added his name to the long list of whole
of truly distinguished scholars who have
given the Hume lecture at Yale
University in years past but first a
word about professor tiser he received
his BA from Oberlin in 1978 and the same
year he moved on to Princeton into the
phd program and at Princeton he spent
eight years doing his PhD which i think
is just about the minimum amount of time
that one can spend doing a PhD in
Buddhist studies and I and our Dean's at
Yale should know this
because we've ever had to supervise a
student into the seventh year and eighth
year and getting nasty letters from the
Dean you know what I mean after spending
a year at University of Southern
Carolina Southern Carolina University of
South California he was snapped up by
Princeton Princeton moves very quickly
in these matters and they know a gem
when they see one and I daresay they
move very quickly that yell couldn't
even get near him he moved to move to
Princeton and there he worked his way up
the academic ladder going from
instructor to assistant professor
associate professor and finally DT
suzuki suzuki professor of buddhist
studies professor taizo is the author of
three major works on Chinese Buddhist
beliefs and practices the first of these
appeared in 1988 and the title is the
ghost festival in medieval China this
was translated into Chinese and
subsequently published in China the
ghost festival for those who know
Japanese its aura bone or the Europe you
lump on festival six years later in 1994
his second book appeared entitled the
scripture of the ten Kings and the
making of purgatory in medieval Chinese
Buddhism his next book in fact came out
about seven eight months ago and it is
called reinventing the way reinventing
the wheel paintings of rebirth in
medieval Buddhist temples and for this
book he received a prestigious French
award the title of which I wouldn't dare
to promise in English because it's
rather difficult to read and beyond that
he has published 20 articles a little
more than 20 articles on Chinese
religion and he has another for that a
forthcoming so you can see he is a very
prolific scholar what is unique about
professor tices work is
his focus on how Buddhism was perceived
and practiced in medieval Chinese
society he's interested in such things
as the the popular legends and beliefs
about Hell the festival's the liturgies
and more recently he seems to have been
extending his research into chinese
buddhist notions of paradise when i look
at the work of Professor thaisa I cannot
help but note how the field of Buddhas
how far the field of Buddhist studies
has evolved and how much richer it has
become since the time I took my first
course in Buddhist studies at kumazawa
University in 1954 half a century ago
and thought to believe Buddhist studies
in those days in Japan at least and I
hasten to add in the United States as
well in the 1950s there was virtually
nobody in this country doing Buddhism in
a serious academic way one exception was
a Kenneth Chen who has a lecture at
Harvard and produced perhaps 15 superb
articles on on chinese buddhism various
aspects of chinese buddhism the material
culture the economics of chinese
buddhism and so on and was outrageously
denied tenure at Harvard after being
there about 10 years needless to say
Princeton grabbed him very quickly too
when Javed made this stupid blunder and
he became professor at Princeton
University but I guess that was before
the time of Professor taizo so what what
Buddhist studies consisted of when I
studied it and the way I I've handled it
was largely the study of canonical texts
in Buddhism you probably know there is a
huge canon of scripture and the standard
edition that we use for study of
japanese chinese buddhism Korean
Vietnamese is a is a collection called
at I show cannon which has 85 volumes
and each volume has on average a
thousand pages so you're speaking of a
scripture that's running eighty-five
thousand pages and I forget how many
titles are in this is whether it's 2000
5000
many I can't quite recall but that was
the way Buddhist studies was approached
and I was at the taco misawa University
getting my training and then at tokyo
university and the buddhism was taught
generally with it with an introductory
lecture and that is one introductory
course and then you went right into
texts and the professor would choose a
text that he was interested in sometimes
that the student was interested in was
negotiated and then you would sit with
that text two hours a week or three
hours a week very often and you'd read
that text which was typically in Chinese
I should say didn't work in Indian
Buddhism per se the text was in Chinese
and you'd read it alongside the
commentaries of the succeeding dynasties
to see how everybody had read that text
and then if there were modern Japanese
studies of it which often there were
you'd read those as well and that
constituted that constituted Buddhist
studies I one of the things you get out
of it is a very good knowledge of text
and how to read a text and how to use
commentaries on how to use dictionaries
for better or for worse that's what I
brought to the United States to Yale
when I was appointed here in 1968 and my
students I don't know if they're running
in the audience say maybe one or two
they SAT through these long seminars in
my home I conducted all the seminars in
my home because I have a large library
all the canonical materials and that was
there that was their introduction to
Buddhist studies and they did well I
think the students and they went out to
the various universities to teach but
there are people who had some questions
about this approach to Buddhism and one
of my students who go nameless for the
moment had published a very an excellent
book that won an award and the reviews
of the book were very good except for
one review that was rather critical and
the gist of that review was this book is
as good as can be expected from someone
who is a student of Weinstein's and
thinks that all of Buddhism can be dealt
with in texts and texts alone very
unfair because I know there are other
approaches to Buddhism it just was that
I was not trained in those
and if this wasn't only my problem but
my colleagues at the other universities
phillippe on polski at Columbia who did
chinese buddhism and zen and lewis
lancaster at berkeley and mass nagato me
at Harvard all of us were primarily
primarily text people but I was in
addition to my studies of course when I
was in Japan I would travel around visit
Buddhist temples and when I was seeing
Buddhist temples things that were very
difficult to recognize with what I was
reading in the Buddhist texts I can
recall one occasion about many occasions
actually I went to a temple mrs. n
temple and as is typical in Zen temples
you of an image of Shakyamuni Buddha in
the center and doggin bogans ng the
founder of the japanese soto school on
one side Kazon zheng jie on the other
side another one of the patriarchs and
right in front of the image there is a
right in front of the image of
Shakyamuni Buddha and somewhat lower
altar there was a very bizarre-looking
deity there and I said to the abbot as I
said what's that who is that and he said
to me Kotoko se Kyung which was a name I
had never heard before in my life having
at that point already read lots of tons
of Buddha stuff I said how do you write
it in characters knee rotating
characters and I had never seen it the
word say Qin means sacred or holy prince
and kotoko means the power or virtue of
fire so what's this doing in a Buddhist
temple he said well you know it's here
when I went back to the University I
asked my professors about it I said what
about this one this image and they said
oh well you know that's that's not
Buddhism that's a Japanese phrase was
shot session coda so do his accession
poda which means it's a kind of course
religious faith and he said young to
bother with it on another visit lo and
behold again at the zen temple I see
images of a row of images so I asked
again who is this I'm told it's the ten
Kings ok I had not heard about the ten
Kings in my studies and these ten Kings
the most bizarre names you can imagine
one of them was for example called the
king of the metropolis all right which
is nothing to do with Buddhism obviously
again bringing this up with my
professors they just said you don't
bother with that here we study texts so
there were of course obviously lots out
there that I didn't know about and never
myself incorporated into my lectures at
at Yale viewed from this perspective
professor Thaisa an accomplished budala
jizz deserves high praise for going
beyond the traditional canonical
approach to Buddhist studies by
examining the rich dunhuang finds the
apocryphal Buddhist scriptures
liturgical manual manuals and the like
which for the most part had not been
subject to rigorous scrutiny by Buddhist
scholars there were some people of
course to work in those areas but these
would not Buddhist scholars these would
be typically anthropologist ethnologist
sometimes people in the field of
literature sociologists but you did not
have respectable Buddhist scholars for
the most part working in those areas
professor Thaisa has quite literally
expanded the boundaries of Buddhist
studies and situated the study of
medieval Chinese belief and practice
firmly within the field of Buddhist
studies by his groundbreaking research
the title of today's lecture is the
construction of paradise in Chinese
Buddhist liturgies and in a sense may
reflect professor tizer zone evolution
from the dystopia of Buddhist purgatory
and hungry ghosts to the Utopia of the
Buddhist paradise and that is what he
calls paradise or the old time is called
pure land I trust the same thing so
please join me in welcoming professor
tiser to Yale University
thank you very much Stanley for your
very kind introduction you'll be very
happy to know that the study of Zeus
machine coal is founded still on the
careful study of texts and the use of
commentaries and an end encyclopedias
it's person it's precisely what we how
we train our students so it's found that
your your generations foundation is is
still quite solid and still quite alive
I also want to express my appreciation
to the human oriole lecture committee
and the Council on East Asian Studies
when Han saucy first invited me to
deliver this lecture last year I worried
that I was not qualified to follow in
the footsteps or further the mission of
Edward Hicks Hume as you know dr. Hume
was born in India in 1876 and educated
at Yale and Johns Hopkins after some
years in India Hume dedicated himself to
establishing hospitals and medical
colleges in China he later served as the
first president of Yale in China and
after an illustrious career passed away
in 1957 the year after I was born in
pathfinders of the world's missionary
crusade George Sherwood Eddie rights as
follows dr. Hume saw that the medical
missions were a means of breaking down
prejudice of winning confidence and
securing a friendly atmosphere for the
Christian message in preparing my
lecture I realized that I have more in
common with Edward Hume than I had at
first thought we are both interested in
Chinese concepts of well-being were both
drawn to the complex interaction between
Chinese traditions and the religions
that originated elsewhere although i
don't share Humes commitment
to Protestantism like him I am also
interested in what happens to Chinese
souls after they have passed away which
brings me to the topic of my lecture
today what happens after death in the
Chinese Buddhist world view the death of
unenlightened folks like you and me is
simply the beginning of a transition to
another form of life the symbol of the
wheel which constantly turns is an apt
representation of the cyclical
representation of life and death this
19th century painting from the Rubin
collection in New York depicts the six
realms into which one can be reborn
humans occupy the top right the top left
segment actually contains two realms of
rebirth at the top at the top are gods
to whom the Buddha appears as a musician
playing a lute below them into the left
or the asuras or demigods engaged in
battle with the gods these are the lower
three destinies animals are at the left
hungry ghosts are at the right their
necks as thin as needles and their
bellies distended from hunger at the
bottom is hell where beings are sent for
an unusually long lifetime of torment as
the Buddhist studies scholars in the
audience know this understanding of
repeated birth and death or the process
of samsara is one of the basic building
blocks of Buddhism everywhere the gods
lead long and happy lives but in their
next lifetime they're going to be reborn
in a lower path in this world view the
only release from continued suffering
whether as God human or hell being is to
achieve Nirvana the extinction of
suffering and life as we know it
sometime around the beginning of the
Common Era perhaps in Central Asia or
India other concepts of the afterlife
began to take hold in Buddhism with some
reservations I will use the general
category of paradise to cover these new
ideas based on the meaning of the Greek
word paradisus garden or enclosed Park
but it is indeed basically like the Pure
Land that Professor weinstein mentioned
what is paradise in Buddhist thinking
what does it look like what does it mean
how is it put together our answers will
vary depending on the particular
representation of paradise we are
considering this slide shows a wall
painting from a tenth century cave
temple at you lean in northwest China it
depicts a paradise seen in this case a
pure land or field for the exercise of
salvation this pure land is overseen by
the large Buddha in the center he's not
the historical Buddha Shakyamuni but
rather the Buddha Buddha amita his
sanskrit name literally means infinite
life also known as Amitabha infinite
light as befits someone who's achieved
the status of Buddha or awakened one his
body is so huge that he Dwarfs his
closest followers i canõt graphically he
is distinguished by a halo by a mandorla
behind him golden colored skin which has
turned nearly black due to oxidation
oxidization in this case the throne on
which he sits and bodily features
marking his status as a perfected being
such as the round bump on the top of his
head or wish nisha the wisp avoid hair
in the middle of his forehead or knock
Asia and elongated earlobes following
the dictum that size and beauty are
indicators of one's karma or deeds the
next most important class of beings
consists of the two figures at the side
of the Buddha there Bodhisattvas beings
who dedicate themselves formally over
many lifetimes to helping other achieve
sentient beings achieve salvation
another kind of being is found on the
platform in front of the main assembly
these are entertainers for musicians on
each side playing a variety of string
and wind instruments and a muscular
Bongo bearing dancer in the middle there
is also a gaily colored bird his wings
and plumage accentuated whose beauty and
own singing voice pleases the audience
the lower two corners of the composition
contains small Buddha figures with their
own adoring public this is the bottom
right where the youngest residents of
the pure land appear six flower children
are clustered around the lower right
platform one pair is at the bottom of
the steps further right underneath the
stairs two other babies look like
they're frolicking in the water one is
holding on to the stairway above while
the other is diving underwater with his
toes sticking out more serious play is
going on above them one baby's already
seated on top of the platform he kneels
on one lotus bud but its spread petals
spread underneath and it's he's holding
another lotus in his hands he seems
ready to use the only object he knows a
flower to make an offering to the Buddha
behind him the sixth baby is pictured
just prior to the moment of birth he
awaits rebirth while sitting inside the
lotus bud which our artist has rendered
in translucent white so that we can
discern him as if he's meditating even
with this simple analysis of the
paradise painting we've learned a lot
about what paradise is and how it's
constructed the painting uses body size
ornate pneus of clothes and jewelry and
proximity to the Buddha to demarcate a
scale a sociological scale
the Buddha's are most exalted and
powerful followed by their Bodhisattva
systems they all grace this pure land
where musicians dancers and fabulous
birds entertain the residents the newest
entrance to paradise are slowly learning
their way figuring out how to move from
the innocent world of child's play to
adoration or a direct encounter with the
mighty being at the center of the scene
there's also an entertaining narrative
being spun around the margins of the
great icon let me step back from the
material I presented thus far and
restate my argument in more abstract
terms how does the 10th century painting
accomplish the construction of paradise
it does so first by providing a
representation a determinant picture of
paradise that includes its constituent
parts and it also delineate the
relationship between the constituent
parts the painting also works because in
its original setting in a temple it
presumes a certain relationship between
the viewer and the viewed the Lord
Buddha not only dominates the
composition he also commands reverence
from the viewer because he's presented
iconically frontally in an iconic pose
in the rest of my talk today I'll ask
similar questions about the construction
of paradise in Chinese Buddhist
liturgies just as a painting offers a
visual representation of the Pure Land a
liturgy or script for ritual provides
and enacted or performative
representation of the other world about
the liturgies then I will ask what is
the nature of the representation whether
it's produced through visual means or
through narrative or through ritual we
can ask the same questions of all these
media what are the aesthetics of that
which is represented how are the parts
of the painting or the parts of the
ritual related to one another what
languages do they use
what is their style and what are the
dynamics involved in the conduct or the
practice of religion part 2 discussion
of Chinese Buddhist liturgies liturgies
have been an essential part of Buddhism
in China ever since foreign merchants
and monks applying the Silk Road first
carried statues of the Buddha to the
Middle Kingdom and showed local people
how to pay respect to their golden
images already in the 4th century
biographies of the efforts of Buddhist
monks and such want to compile liturgies
full fortnightly monastic confession for
the ordination of monks and for
ceremonies administered to laypeople
this last category the ritual services
provided by monks to lay people in other
monks is what I'm going to focus on
today modern historians of Chinese
Buddhism are fortunate to have a wealth
of information about ritual life
especially in the eighth through tenth
centuries thanks to the amazing corpus
of manuscripts discovered along the Silk
Road especially those that do long early
in the 20th century out of roughly
50,000 manuscripts taken out of the
so-called library cave at the Mogao
caves in dune wang about three or four
hundred consist wholly or partly of
liturgies composed by local Buddhist
priests at doon wang for the performance
of lay rituals i've been teaching these
texts from jun wang in my graduate
seminars on and off for about 10 years
now and hope to start working along them
more systematically soon the title
usually given to them is jai one or you
n 1 jai 1 i've been translating as feast
text you n 1 as prayer text the words I
of course has many meanings in the
history of Chinese religion in a set of
texts in question it refers to a wide
range of rituals conducted by members of
the Buddhist clergy for different
sponsors the rights include funerals and
memorial rituals
wright's surrounding childbirth the
curing of sickness the dedication of
temples the casting of statues and
copying of sutras ordination into the
monkhood the death of livestock prayers
for rain the digging of wells
celebration of the Buddha's birthday
birthday celebrations for local people a
good silkworm harvest the sighting of
graves and the building of houses some
of the feast texts are individual
compositions written for a specific
purpose at a specific time and place
others are formulaic in nature collated
into handy booklets the physical form of
the manuscripts offers many clues about
who wrote the texts and how they were
used the liturgical manuals i'm studying
come in two basic forms formats the
scroll and the codex this example is
Stein number 38 75 the text is
incomplete and it's a relatively short
scroll consisting of just two sheets of
paper glued together and see the blue
line here there's writing on both erecto
and the verse show the content of the
text is a prayer formulary offering a
model liturgy for the performance of
different kinds of rituals leaving space
for the efficient to fill in the
specific circumstances of specific
rights our text is entitled explicitly
tool zhou jai one in one volume or
assorted various ritual texts in one
volume on the first page is the first
text cheating won an invitation liturgy
it continues to the left and then again
over to the reverse side where the
second text begins here jia tan one
jetton want a liturgy for establishing
an altar
this is a codex or a glued booklet
containing liturgies for a wide range of
rights primarily memorial rituals and
pre mortuary rights designed to pave
one's way after death as to what kind of
paradise that road led to I'll continue
that discussion in a moment the original
booklet consisted of 52 sheets of paper
glued together written on front and back
making up a total of 104 pages it's
about 4 by 6 inches it was so thick in
fact packing in a total of thirty-six
liturgies that it eventually split in
two just like any well used paperback
this is the front cover like the short
scroll I showed you this one is too is a
formulary containing full liturgies and
sections of liturgies without anybody's
name filled in instead the text leaves a
blank space or uses a Chinese equivalent
of the words sponsors name here or fill
in the number of days after death
whenever it reaches that point in the
liturgy what you see here is the page
that ends a liturgy for a memorial
service supposed to be conducted once
every seven days after death until the
49th day the fill in the blank mark is
here right above the arrow in the
sentence that reads the previous
sentence reads way fulshear paying our
only reliance is merit and then the
sentence in question reads cool your mo
teacher ton young jin shan doll and this
mark right here is the mole or the fill
in the blank mark a translation would be
there for on the such-and-such seventh
day after death we use this merit to
advance the spirit on the path
this is the back of the back cover of
the same codex this particular
manuscript was used by a ritual
specialist who carried it from one
performance to the next it's small size
and binding format meant that it could
be held in the hands and read aloud
without requiring a table or a stand in
order to understand how paradise is
constructed through these liturgies we
need first to look briefly at how the
texts work my general approach is to
view them as performative literature to
understand the genre the text I place it
in the context of the ritual for which
it serves as script much of the language
in the text is meta pragmatic it is
first of all pragmatic because it the
text in being performed accomplishes
something but it's metachromatic
pragmatic further in that some phrases
in the texts refer self reflexively to
the actions that the text is performing
in my analysis I also attend to the
registers of language used in the text
there are different voices in the text
they range from the officiating priest
to the sponsor which could be a grieving
family or group of monks oral a society
or the voice could be the words spoken
by monastic and lay participants in the
rituals the gods and spirits who assist
in the performance and the spirit of the
deceased who is thought to take part in
the performance also elsewhere I'm
publishing a more detailed linguistic
analysis in mostly in articles in
Chinese since until now these texts have
been the preserve of Chinese scholars in
the PRC and Taiwan but today i would
like to lead you quickly through the
basic outline of one memorial ritual so
you can see where I'm headed without
understanding the sequence of the whole
ritual we won't be able to understand
the last part which is where the
construction of paradise is actually
completed
now I'd like to guide you through the
different sections of a generic memorial
ritual in this case for a departed
mother the liturgies contained in a
longer formulary consisting of memorial
rights for a range of different kinds of
people in the world view of the medieval
monk there's a memorial for father for
brothers and sisters senior and junior
for senior monks and junior monks and so
forth this manuscript is part of Stein
number 343 I divided it into sections A
through H section a opens with praises
of the Buddha it contrasts the death
that all normal people suffer with the
final liberation that only Buddha's can
achieve the language is very flowery
parallel prose using abstract or
indirect words to refer to the ritual
occasion it's a literary sermon section
b is quite different in language it
turns to the here and now of ritual and
announces the basic intention of the
current memorial service and this word
je is in fact used within several
liturgies to title this section in our
case the section reads and now our
purpose in holding incense and kneeling
piously beside the foot of the incense
brasher is a service of fortune or merit
offered on behalf of our deceased mother
only such and such seventh day of merit
this section of the liturgy stands back
from the performance it comments meta
pragmatically on what is going on in the
service itself it explains in abstract
terms the action that is taking place
section C of the liturgy offers capsule
praises of the beneficiary of the right
like other forms of eulogistic writing
in China here the person's virtues are
related to his or her station in life
the formulary for deceased mother for
instance refers to her for wifely
virtues and then laments her early
passing passing the phrases here the
praises begin she deserved to stay long
in this world rearing children and
considering grandchildren but how could
we have known the tunes of karma are
hard to stop and suddenly the candle is
snuffed out by the wind section D
reviews the actions that were undertaken
in the past leading up to this ritual
while section ease shifts to the present
summarizing what actions are being
performed now in order to create a stock
of merit section f is the performative
crux of the whole piece in my analysis
if the words in this section are not
pronounced then the goal of the ritual
is not achieved the fruit of the actions
already performed is left floating and
the intended beneficiary of the right is
left literally in limbo by speaking this
single sentence the results of the
actions of their participants in the
ritual are gathered up and bestowed upon
the beneficiary the single sentence
reads we gather together the superlative
merit this unlimited good cause and use
it first to offer help to her to see
soul and departed consciousness section
G consists of prayers that specify
precisely how the benefit should be
enjoyed here our memorial ritual
constructs a paradise it does so by
narrating a course that the mother's
spirit is supposed to follow in future
lifetimes the text reads
way you're in by Holly doll we pray that
the tuft of white hair show her the way
Ian Xiang Yu fontegne that she is sent
to Brahmas heaven in one moment of
thought only in hua Xiong that she'd be
reborn through magical transformation in
a Red Lotus China yo you fog law and
that she traveled to a Buddha land in
the space of an shut up or an instant
I'll have more to say about this
afterlife journey in a few moments for
now let me draw your attention to the
importance of the word you're an in most
liturgies it's rendered in the causative
compound you ensure or we pray that she
we pray that she be caused to this
formulary for a mother's memorial
service does not end by assigning the
benefits solely to the deceased after
this section it continues in sections
that I would label f2 and g2 and f3 and
g3 to transfer good merit and then
specify the results for two other groups
of beans the second group is the family
undertaking the memorial service and the
last beneficiaries consists of sentient
beings currently residing in hell the
last section of the liturgy section H is
a benediction I choose the word
carefully from little from the Latin
been a plus de querer meaning to speak
well most benedictions are in for
character phrasing suitable for chanting
the poster for my lecture includes
several of these four character phrases
benedictions at the end of a memorial
service the one in the this particular
liturgy for the deceased mother reads
may those possessing form and mind yo
celula sheen all attained a way of
enlightenment jia chang ja da
I'd like now to turn and consider how
paradise is constructed through the
memorial ritual I'm going to focus in
particular on section G of the dune want
prayers analyzing how they construct
another world the this is the liturgy
we're at a moment ago it's section G or
prayers for rebirth as you know it
speaks of four distinct locations or
movements one the tuft of white hair to
that she ascends to Brahmas heaven in
one moment of thought three that she be
reborn through magical transformation
and for that she traveled to a Buddha
land in the space of an instant these
symbols are loaded so I'm going to take
a moment to unpack each one of them the
tough to avoid hair is a unique
attribute of old Buddhist although the
white hair on amitayus his brow is
particularly well known it was the ninth
in a series of 16 visualization
exercises the harem its array of light
that guides the deceased spirit to the
next world the second location is Brock
Maz heaven it's one of the higher
heavens but it's not a pure land it
lacks a Buddha it's located well above
the realm of the four heavenly kings
guarding the side of mount sumeru it's
higher still than the heaven of 33 the
tries trim sha in which indra and the 32
other gods reside the third phrase in
the prayer refers to a red lotus which
we might i dint might identify as a
lotus growing in a pond in a Pure Land
it's other possible association is with
a red lotus flower held by the thousand
armed of a low key tessera to wit in of
a low key test for us 40th left hand the
illusion if that is the illusion is to a
well-known ritual translated by the ton
trick Master mo Guevara in the 8th
century in which the spirent to rebirth
in the heavens is directed to hold a red
lotus blossom in his hands
fourth there is the instantaneous
transport to a Buddha land that is a
paradise graced by a living Buddha how
are these four locations or these four
movements in the prayer related to each
other I believe that our liturgist had a
clear idea of the afterlife and a good
understanding about how to guide people
there the monks of doing wrong work with
the audience engaged in the performance
and they understood the spirits
undergoing the journey most prayers
eventually invoke the final goal the
practitioner at the end will have a
direct encounter with a living Buddha
hearing the Dharma directly from the
mouth of an enlightened being or gazing
upon a fully perfected being then
enables one to achieve enlightenment
particularly quickly gaining direct
access to a living Buddha in paradise
usually does not happen immediately that
is the ultimate goal but the formularies
also lay out a journey and I would like
now to investigate further what the
nature of that journey is afterlife the
journey is marked by many proximate
goals or stopping points our liturgies
typically envisioned a series of after
lives prior to final enlightenment the
ranking is pretty clear simply avoiding
rebirth in the three lower paths is the
most humble wish that's typically the
start of the souls pilgrimage the
heavens come next the guard gods
guarding the four directions around
mount Sumeru the gods on the peak of
mount Sumeru in Hendrick indras heaven
of 33 and above that the gods in Brahmas
heaven or the formless realms after
these lower Buddha less heavens
Trish to heaven where Maitreya as a
bodhisattva before he becomes a Buddha
currently resides last comes a direct
encounter with a Buddha exoteric
Buddhism knew several important Buddhist
each with his own land one could be
reborn in flower in Omagh Titus's
Western land of bliss and then emerge
quickly or slowly depending on one's
karmic roots to face amitayus directly
or one could be reborn and by shoujo
gurus pure land in the east or one could
join Maitreya in his rebirth on jumbo
vibha here on earth in an assembly
around the dragon flower tree there
Maitreya will achieve enlightenment
become a Buddha and preach the Dharma to
millions of sentient beings some prayers
are rather precise about the set time
sequence in the afterlife they explain
how the beneficiary will first be reborn
in tuition to heaven alongside the
future Maitreya not yet a Buddha and
then in a subsequent life the deceased
will accompany Maitreya in his dissent
and witness him bring deliverance to his
listeners in the dragon flower assembly
one liturgy for repentance ceremony
offers this prayer in time to come may
all the disciples all those disciples
practicing this right of repentance
achieve rebirth together we pray that
they encounter maitreya buddha in tushie
to heaven and that in the time of King
Shonka they follow the Buddha in his
rebirth below and hear him preach the
Dharma in the three dragon flower
assemblies
other prayers freely mix the deities and
their rounds but nevertheless
orchestrate a fitting entrance into a
Pure Land a piece entitled graveside
lament directs the performers to chant
the names of deities ten times amitayus
Buddha should be invoked three times of
a low-key test for a bodhisattva three
times mahama procto Bodhisattva three
times and she to garba Bodhisattva once
for a total of ten then the liturgy
proceeds with a transfer of merit and
the prayers for rebirth the prayers read
the both the transfer of merit and then
the prayers read as follows first the
transfer of merit the merit from the ten
recitations will enrich the deceased
soul and he will be born miraculously in
a Pure Land we prayed at the flower
platform and flower canopy empty within
welcome him and that the jeweled seat
and golden bed vacant come to greet him
it continues in the Hall of money jewels
may he hear the preaching about
suffering and emptiness in the pool of
the eight forms of deliverance that he
wash away the filth of ignorance we pray
that oval okie tessera and maha stahma
propped up lead him to the west and in
front of the venerable Maitreya he hear
the preaching clearly the combination of
the three deities of the Western
Paradise with shitty garba Bodhisattva
is not well attested in the canonical
literature that should not prejudice us
however in appreciating the coherence of
this vision of the Otherworld all four
deities have the power to assist the
spirit of the deceased as it moves from
the grave to the higher realm the spirit
is conveyed there in this liturgy in the
proper vehicle a floating
anna peed bed made of flowers and gold
once the Spirit has arrived in the Pure
Land it's purified further and here's
the Dharma directly from the mouth of
the of my trail
to return to the abstract terms that I
introduced to my analysis of paradise
paintings let me ask what attitude to
the liturgical texts take toward the
representation of paradise and what are
the aesthetics of the ritual experience
recall for a moment the way that
visualization texts work the exercise of
visualization teaches the meditator how
to construct a mental image of specific
features paradise moving from one part
of the scene to the next the Buddha's
wisp avoid hair then the blazing
radiance of his skin are visualized and
so on furthermore texts like the Sutra
on the visualization of amitayus
explains how various grades of
practitioners will move through a series
of post-mortem incarnations eventually
reaching supreme perfect enlightenment
here the dominating logic is sequence
the visualization texts themselves
follow the logic of sequence the process
of visualization proceeds from one step
to the next just as the narrative in
which the visualization is taught
consists of episode after episode our
liturgical sources the prayers are
structured by a similar logic of
sequence they are one procedure after
the next thus rather than promulgating a
simplistic faith in the power of
amitayus to solve all problems in once
and rather than promising a single
eternal life in paradise our liturgies
take their participants on a disciplined
journey over many lifetimes ending in
complete enlightenment
you
I turned out to part 3 part b of my
lecture which I have entitled sites of
sites and i'll spell those words for you
in a moment i suggested that in some
respects the liturgical texts avail
themselves of the pattern of sequence
shared with visualization practices and
narrative texts in other ways however
the liturgies employ the methods of
painted representations of paradise
remember the wall painting from alien we
saw earlier it's not a complete
description of amitayus as pure land it
leaves out many details while it adds
embellishment to others note for
instance the way in which buildings and
architectural details here occupy over
one half of the picture space obviously
this is the choice of the artist in
keeping with the medieval artistic
conventions governing two-dimensional
representations of paradise these are
not necessarily the details that other
interpreters of the pure land would
choose to emphasize in their
representations to take one far-flung
example consider the drawings of the
Pure Land made by my undergraduate
students in teaching Buddhist literature
I often have them read the longer
amitayus sutra and then before showing
the many paintings i distribute colored
pencils and paper and ask them to draw
the scene that they have just read about
as you can see their interpretations are
quite interesting some are taken with a
different color trees the cool ponds and
the buildings other modern interpreters
are taken with a description of the
spontaneous inspired music that wafts
through paradise rather than drawing a
picture of a musician this sketch
portrays musical notes floating up into
the sky my point in displaying this art
is to show that any representation of
the pure land is selectively
it must choose a relatively small set of
features often representing them
emblematical II a similar process of
selection is apparent in the memorial
rituals conducted by Buddhist monks
until home the section of the ritual
dealing with afterlife is relatively
short so in fact the liturgist had only
two or four sentences at each of which
it was at most seven characters long in
which to describe paradise it is fitting
then that the language in this part of
the memorial ritual consists of sites in
the Pure Land I mean the word site here
in at least two ways the first spelled
SI te meaning the place where a
structure is located when I finished
translating enough of these manuscripts
and publish a book of liturgies I will
test it out on my students what pictures
will they draw a paradise having read
only liturgies my prediction is that
their pictures will be stocked with wisp
of white hair between the Buddha's
browse a red lotus flower dangling down
from heaven three evil destinies down at
the bottom of the drawing a baby or two
emerging from a lily pond and lots of
people crowded around a dragon flower
tree because these are the locations
these are the sites that recur in the
prayer texts the other sense of sight is
spelled si gh T referring to the Faculty
of seeing or that which is seen what
would a traveler to the other world
observe the answer is laid out in the
prayer section of our liturgies these
sites are created through their
collective performance of the right and
the Annunciation the speaking aloud of
the prayer the prayer explains exactly
what sites the beneficiary will see
exactly what sites the deceased spirit
will see as it moves through the
Otherworld
old as a result of the good deeds
performed by his or her family as a
collective ritual the memorial service
also inculcates a vision of the
afterlife that soothes and engages the
living participants at the same time led
by a monk who recites the liturgy the
living members refer to in our text as
Jesse alga those utmost in filial piety
imagined for themselves in concrete
terms the experiences that their loved
one right now in the time of the ritual
is undergoing the living family
participates in constructing a shared
vision paradise part 3 see mind and body
you may have noticed that I've used the
words soul in my lecture today but wait
doesn't Buddhism teach a Nevada the
doctrine that denies a permanent self
undoubtedly so as Nagas Cena famously
put it there is no permanent self
affirmed as Co Ichi Shin o hara has
recently shown Buddhist monks worried
that mortuary ceremonies might reinforce
the illusion of a permanent soul but we
have to remember what our informants
mean by permanent they mean lasting not
just a long time they mean lasting
forever what buddhists denied was not
the everyday belief that people have
personalities or even continuous selves
or that beings are reborn from life one
lifetime to the next in accord with
their previous deeds this was not open
to doubt rather the Buddhists were
arguing against a very specific claim
the belief that the essential substrate
of the person indoors forever the
Buddhist view allows plenty of room for
proxy
selves for aspects or elements of the
person to last from one moment to the
next or for many many lifetimes our
liturgies are no exception to this
Buddhist belief in proximate selves
aspects of the person that last for many
lifetimes but not forever they refer
over and over again in different words
to the portions of the individual that
are reborn from one lifetime to the next
look at the words used by the monks who
wrote our liturgies they used words like
deceased soul Wang Ling departed
consciousness to shirt dark spirits
Johann and so on this consciousness
bearing entity is constructed by the
liturgy it receives the good karma
produced in the memorial ritual and
while the corpse may be cold in the
grave and subject to different treatment
by different ritual specialists the
Spirit has moved on the Spirit is what
progresses on to the next life and
eventually achieve enlightenment let me
conclude then by noting that the
floating consciousness to which the
right ministers is not purely ethereal
it assumes bodily form in accordance
with the realm in which it travels if
traveling through the lower levels of
the cosmos it might be male or female
but Buddhist texts are very clear that
at higher and purer levels of paradise
it only has a male body it might hear
the Dharma song by birds but even then
the conscious body still requires ears
to hear music in short Bodhi requires a
body enlightenment cannot happen apart
from embodiment and that I think brings
us back to the concern
of edward hume for whom the cure of
souls required also a healthy body thank
you I'm happy I'm happy to take
questions I shall I just feel them from
from the podium happy to take questions
and comments I know there are many
specialists in in the art and the
literature of the Otherworld present so
please yes
you'll have to could you stand up and
turn around so that everybody can hear
you Roderick I can hear you well but yes
is
well in that sense the paintings and the
liturgies are consistent they these
vehicles are sent down and they're empty
right and one person per vehicle one
soul per vehicle and then the soul
ascends into the into the vehicle and
then rise it right to the appropriate
place to continue life in some form or
another yes
ah I gave you a a I focused on the the
ending of the liturgies the beginning
portions what I called what I've labeled
section section be especially reads very
much like a eulogy like like for mo
eulogistic writing that you see in other
memorials memorial settings other
funerary settings and those go on at
some length in a different register of
language about the virtues of the
deceased they lament early passing so
those give voice to other kinds of
emotions ones that are certainly first
glorifying the deceased and then
lamenting their passing so I that's
where that's where I see it in the
liturgies in these liturgies there are
not many but there are some graveside
rachel rights professor Shinohara has
has has written about some of them found
in vinia materials and and in non vinie
materials in a cannon and there are some
graveside rites among the do hung
manuscripts but they're not a lot most
of most of them are memorial rights and
they were carried on quite a long time
49 days after death and then a hundred
days and 1 year in three years if people
were not worried about their ancestors
those rights couldn't have been
performed so I even when the emotions of
the living family are not directly
spoken about in the text I think we have
to assume that that was part of the
motivation for going to
monks to perform the rituals in the
first place I see it indirectly more
than I do directly yes speak up so they
hear you in the back please
uh because it because eventually the
well two reasons one one is
psychologically if there's a if there's
a permanent soul we act in a selfish way
and that's that's always a bad idea in
the Buddhist tradition to be egocentric
the other reason is that in theory there
has to be a way out so because personal
identity is based on ignorance
ultimately in this world view there has
to be a way out of ignorance and craving
and the way out is to do away with the
illusory self so there's a practical
reason as well as a good philosophical
reason yes I I think what they mean and
they refer it there's instant instant
aim instant tenaya tea the idea of
something happy birth happening
instantly occurs indeed in that phrase
and also in the idea of magical birth
hua Xiong in Chinese I believe it's
Paducah yoni and Sanskrit which we know
from abhidharma sources as well that's
the transformation in which you don't
have to assume another bodily form you
can just snap appear like that in in
heaven or in a Pure Land those those
words I think refer to rebirth that
happens in an instant instantaneously
but that's not the end of the story
there's another rebirth after that so
when it occurs in our liturgies I I see
that as laying out in the
birth she will be reborn instantaneously
and then after that her next birth will
occur either quickly or slowly there's
certainly a Bardot and these same ritual
texts have what I would call a Bardo or
the same thing a Bardo period in a Bardo
place and that's administered by the ten
Kings so at any moment at any point in
these rituals that's where the deceased
spirit could be right now and and the
fact that some of these memorial rights
are explicitly titled for the ten Kings
i think is ink is conclusive proof that
that's where they were thought to be
sometimes during this period so I did I
didn't read those but I'll in the future
I hope to to produce them for you and
show them to you yes fresa park
I'm gonna try and find it for you if I
can't find that I won't but I have it
here somewhere
yes oh
this okay so here is simply the Lotus
there's no canopy over it and it's an
astounding painting I never see I have
not seen the original but it's there's a
visual contact between the the Buddha
and the aspiring and you see him
starting as a monk you see him at two
different stages you see the process of
rebirth here so he's down here
meditating or seated perhaps in either
in good health or near the end of his
life he has a what is he looking at he's
looking at the thorn acacia the whisper
white hair here he's led by the light
emitted from or an acacia and then here
he is again this is his journey
transformed he's transformed starting
again as a young person and he's going
to be carried up by mahaprabhu and other
loci touch for so that's happening in an
instant but that's not the end of the
life is how i would if at least the
perspective of the liturgies on reading
seemed to take that is it's a journey of
several lifetimes at least
yes professor named
I well you you I think have written on
this more persuasively than than any of
us and and I I would follow your lead
that is I interpret your approach as
saying that the the images follow an
artistic logic and ought to be evaluated
on their own as an integral religious
vision or an integral program without
saying that they're right or wrong in
relation to the text artists followed
artistic logic by the same token I so
that's one way of that's how I read your
work and I would use a similar logic to
look at the liturgical manuscripts
certainly there in conversation monks
see many of these paintings not this is
a tumba this is a she shot rather
different but monks see many of the
paintings I showed amongst so many of
the paintings I showed but they were
conducting their own rituals and they
were masters of liturgy so rather than
following artistic conventions they
follow the turtle conventions so they
followed eulogistic writing in China the
secular tradition of your logistic
writing which is very flowery on the one
hand but they also followed Buddhist
models of merit transference on the
other hand and those sections are very
pronounced in these
rituals which is one of the reasons I
was interested in them in the first
place because they are there there I
believe they're they're quite prevalent
in in Buddhist practice at all levels of
society and we tend not to not to look
at them that much but the liturgist in
short I think follow their own logic so
to fully answer your question I I would
look at the language in the liturgy
rather than going back to the pictures
rather than going back to the paintings
and the language of the liturgy I'll
think about this as I in the future as I
rate the chapter about this so this is a
very helpful to me to think about it the
language often talks about rebirth
together tonkoon to be reborn together
in the pure land or the members of al a
society hope to be reborn together or in
liturgies for for husbands and wives
they also express a wish to be reborn
together for at least one lifetime right
or one more lifetime in in a certain
place that expression occurs off and
that's how I'd answer it right now
the best examples of course are those in
which there's agenda a shift in gender
and also a shifted species so you know
the two famous ones are the story of the
Naga princess from the Lotus Sutra in in
which which discusses that question and
mullions mother the mother mo-cro van
melle deyana who in her future lifetimes
is she starts off in hell and because of
her son's devotion she slowly works her
way up but as she works her way up of
course she is reborn as a Hungry Ghost
next she's were born as an animal and
its various in the texture very explicit
she's reborn as a dog and the the
somewhat later images we have of that
show her she's not recognizable as a as
a human being she's recognized you know
she's clearly an animal so in that sense
there's a the family feels a connection
to the deceased but they imagine them as
a different species even so certainly a
different gender it's possible there's
one more question one more question
please
soul body is there any comparison bodies
are pretty malleable yeah and and bodies
bodies belong it bodies are defined by
the realm you're in so in heaven you if
you're in heaven by definition you have
the body of a god and the word in
Sanskrit is the same it works in Chinese
as well if you're a diva shining one you
you both are a deity and you reside in
the diva in the in the deities realm if
you're a human being you have a human's
body and and the differences are really
clear gods have huge bodies especially
the bigger happier gods they have very
big bodies hungry ghosts you I would not
appear as a hung if I'm reborn as a
Hungry Ghost I would I would not have
the body i now have so in that sense it
you don't get the same body back
Oh